thank you at 4 30 i'd like to for those
who want to stay and discuss these
groups for the rest of the program and
that sort of thing please stick around
uh after this session okay thomas over
to you
okay
so so i have to apologize in some sense
what i'm going to talk about here is
it's a bit redundant because you already
saw the id algorithm on tuesday
and although i had had it the idea to
rewrite
my plan was to describe the id algorithm
here in terms of uh purely in terms of
potential outcomes so there is a paper
a recent paper
with myself and jamie and earlier that
where we do do that we restrain the id
algorithm in terms of swigs
um uh i'm not going to do that here i
have not had time to retool my
slides but also in a certain sense if
you understand what i'm presenting here
you'll be able to translate it to what
was being done in swigs
relatively um
uh easily and in some sense
yeah so i'm i'm hoping that uh
i i'm guessing that not everybody
completely dropped the id algorithm on
tuesday um and so i'm hoping it's not
completely redundant
oh yes slides yes yes yes
yes you could do induction slide the
name of the slides is like the name of
the slides the previous time it's three
replaced by four
but um
let me find my
just a second
um
i'm getting i'm in the situation here we
are i'm in a situation where zoom is
covering my windows here we go
yes brilliant guess
okay okay great
induction
another triumphant okay so these are my
courses on this
um
so
this is i'm sort of
okay there's a second part this talk i'm
not going to get to the second part of
this talk does connect more closely to
um
what was talked about yesterday so
basically it's talking about
uh how to develop non-parametric
graphical models that capture not just
conditional independence but also other
non-parametric constraints are implied
by latent variable models in fact all of
the other
equality constraints implied by latent
variable models and so that provides a
way of searching
search across a finer class than
mags
um
but i'm not going to have time to get to
that so instead i'm going to tell you
about um
the id algorithm
but i'm going to present it in a
different in a different way slightly
different way
um
so i'll i'll describe the general
identification problem i'll give some
simple examples so
again if you understood everything on
tuesday then this will be will be a kind
of relaxing end to the afternoon at
least this this night and then these
parts may sort of shed some light on
things on tuesday
okay
so intervention distributions
uh so i've got a
tag um g
with variable set v we've got this
distribution that factors according to
the graph
and you know this is the set of parents
and the intervention distribution is
obtained by just removing
the terms from this factorization
corresponding to the variables that are
intervening on and then setting the
parents
uh whenever one of the variables i'm
intervening on shows up as a parent i'm
fixing it to that
the value i'm interviewing
okay so you know to make this concrete
here's our
uh friendly back door uh front door
graph like it's also going to be
backdoor craft as well
um
now when i intervene
on
when i intervene on x i'm going to
remove this term from the factorization
i'm going to have this factorization
representing the joint over l m and y
when i intervene
to set x x
okay um
and
so you know in general given the cause
of down g with distribution
observed distribution like that
if we wish to compute an intervention
distribution we can do it by just
removing those terms from the
factorization and then if we're
interested in a subset
if we say well actually i'm only really
interested in just over a subset of the
variables that are not intervened on
then we can compute that by just
okay and
you might say wait a second this could
be a big sum that could be
computationally a bit expensive you'll
be right but then you know we can use if
we think a bit more we can use the
factorization of the graph to make that
more efficient but just at a high level
we've got a product of terms
for each one for each variable we
haven't intervened on and then we sum
out the
random variables we're not interested in
this is a special case of the g
computation formula robbins
and it was also uh occurred in the
expertise at albert back in 1993 and
then it was you know taken up and
generalized by
well not it gets taken out wasn't
generalized taken out
and considered in more detail in the do
calculus by pearl
um so the key thing i want you to
understand here is that y given do x
equals x is a sum over a product of
terms okay so
productive terms
and so in the same sense these are like
atoms in the sense that any query that
you're interested in can be written as a
sum of products of these guys
but um
okay so here
back to this
instance uh i intervene on x
now i've got this is the distribution
over l m and y went into v not x
but if if you say well i don't really
care about l m i'm more interested in
the distribution of y when i intervene
on x then i just
sum out over l and then my my slides
over those guys and there's my my
formula
um and so sort of the key thing
uh to take away here hopefully you
already got this but just in case not
the key thing to observe is that um
that
this this expression here is not going
to just be the same as y
given uh x equals x tilde because um
that would that would require us to uh
have l equals l
um
a condition line x equals
x tilde in order to um in order to get
that out
okay so
yeah and so sort of again to see that
suppose that in fact
suppose that there was no
effect of m on y
so suppose this red edge was not there
then um
then you know then the joint would
factorize in this way
and then you can sort of see immediately
that well then not surprisingly when i
if i intervene on x then because there's
no
causal path here um
then the distribution of y given do x
equals x
is going to
simplify the sum over l and m
uh it's just uh we'll just simplify down
to
not surprisingly the margin for why
but obviously if we look at this graph
the conditional y given x equals x is
not the same as imaginal because we can
see there's a deconnecting path between
y and x so y depends on x minus n so
this is just
to make plain that correlation is not
causation
okay suppose now that m is unobserved
then
you know so now i don't i have to come
up the task has changed i have to come
up with an identifying expression
that doesn't
involve n
okay
um
because i didn't observe it
so
i can do a little bit of algebra and i
can fiddle around
and
i can end up
just rearranging terms i can express
this
uh in
in terms
that don't involve
m i can just think of it as
y given l and x
setting x equal to x tilde times p of l
equals l sum over l so
many of you will see well that this is
sort of obvious because if i just
maximize our m i could think about this
graph as just x goes to y and then we've
got
l and that's the graph we saw previously
which was back door adjustment and this
is the backdoor adjustment formula
okay
so clear key point here is even if i
didn't observe m then i can still get
the effect of x on y
because it's sort of not surprising
then turn it around now suppose that i
observe m but i don't observe l then
again
if you remember the talk on tuesday
you'll remember the sort of
the claim that uh correct claim that
this
that the effect of x and y is identified
here so just how and you saw it again
just before the break i went through a
derivation using swigs of this fact so
this is sort of for the third time
um
you know how could we how could we see
this well
one way to think about it is
um
why the districts of y were known to be
non-x we could think about that as well
if i could work out the effect of x on m
when i intervene on x and then i could
then find the effect of y
when i intervene on m
i multiply those two things together
um
and then you know
i could say to myself well
uh you know m
the effect of x on m is not confounded
so i could just use the conditional
distribution for that
and then the effect of m on y
well that's just the backdoor formula
again just using x to block the backdoor
path from n to y
so then
you know i can
replace this piece by this
and you know i'm home home and dry
there's my
expression for uh the effect of x on y
and it just has this sort of slightly
interesting feature that x shows up
twice
once here
where we're conditioning on it being set
equal to the value that we've
we've set x to but then it also x is
also showing up as a dummy variable in
here
okay
um
so we can find as we saw we can find
that we can get the effect of
x on y
even if we didn't observe l provided
that we did observe n but you can sort
of see this is one of these games that
we can't go on we can't go on with this
forever
if we didn't see l or m
then we're obviously out of luck because
you know
absent further assumptions we can't
distinguish this graph from this graph
and so we're not able to tell the case
but there's no effect of x and y from
the case where there is an effect of x
and y
okay
so
up to this point we saw i come to you
with a dag
i tell you that certain sets of
variables are observed and then you
could ask me is the effect of x on
y
um identified or not given the variables
that i've observed and we can see that
sometimes it is and sometimes it isn't
so our general identification question
will be you know given a dag
with uh latents or observed h hidden
and disjoint subsets x and y that are
observed we want to know is y given dx
identified from the distribution of the
observed variables
and then
what is an answer that question answer
will either be provided either an
identifying formula it's a function of p
of o
or report that this is not identified
and
there are two sort of reasons for doing
this one is we'd like to characterize
which interventions can be identified
without parametric assumptions okay so
again trying to fit this into a big
picture here
we can think about graphs as indexing
different qualitative assumptions we
might make about causal structure and
here we're trying to work out how far we
can get without making parametric
assumptions
you know we saw that the instrumental
variable model we saw that
if i have discrete variables
then in general we're not able to
identify the effect of um
x on y
but
we might be able to get bounds
or we could put in parametric
assumptions and then then we might get
identification in many different ways
that those assumptions could be put in a
second motivation and this ties in it's
a little bit more
obscure but it ties into the
sort of grand goal of trying to do
discovery is that we could then also
understand which functions of the
observed margin have a causal
interpretation
and that's you know we might think
that's a good idea because
if there are functionals of the observed
mind didn't have a cause of
interpretation then
if we subscribe to
faithfulness type principles we might
imagine that
if
if we discover that there are
constraints on those margins
then those would correspond to the
absence of of causal effects so we could
learn something more about structure
okay so now we've got the latent
projection idea which again
um so what
oh could you talk a little bit more
about what you mean by
um
on the last slide we
want to understand
what functionals
the observed margin have a causal
interpretation
so i guess this is something i so my
understanding
of
a lot of the dag
stuff
is that there's this causal there's this
interventional
and everything we think is causal is is
you know captured in that dis distribute
b
whatever it is you want to know about it
we're telling you how you can find find
that dis distribution
um in what's and i whereas you know
potential out out
comes
uh your
tree
treatment effect is some
uh mean
so i guess like what do you what do you
mean by
what in the i guess i missed the link
how
the the stuff above is going to help you
understand
which
functionals have a causal
interpretation and what that means okay
i'm going to respond with a very quick
answer which is uh have a causal
interpretation given a specific
underlying dagwood lens okay so the idea
is if i give you a dag with latency then
then we i'm going to come up just in the
way in generalizing examples i've shown
you before we're going to then come up
with
um we're going to come up with uh
um
functions of distribution
so so for example to give you just go
back to the example i looked at at the
end of the previous lecture with the g
formula of uh
so if you remember the example where i
had a b c d on
a and c were treatments and
uh y
we had a confounder between b and the
final outcome
you might you might find out that uh
let me just see if i can open that
here
answers the questions and sense
quickly comes up yay okay
so
here
this will answer this
okay
so recall this graph we had this graph
you can remember the original dag
so we saw this functional right sum over
b p of b given a d given a b and c
has a causal interpretations the
distribution of d when i intervene on a
and c
okay
now
if there was no edge from a to d
then it would it would be the case that
this function was not a function of a
okay that is a constraint that uh you
wouldn't think of naturally in any other
way right it would seem very odd to say
okay
you know i'm going to multiply together
this conditional distribution in this
conditional distribution sum over b and
then i'm then going to end up with
something that's not a function of a i
mean it would look like a miracle right
if if i didn't tell you that it came
from this this graph you would say well
that's some weird constraint
i'm indeed
you know this is the verma constraint
actually this is this the constraint
that this thing does not depend on a is
what's known as the sort of
famous verma constraint
and um
abstinent causal interpretation it's
very hard to you know you wouldn't
necessarily be able to
uh to see how that could arise as a
constraint
and so basically what i'm telling you is
that
causal identification results can be
parlayed into
a way of coming up with um
a non-parametric constraints that are
implied by
dag factorizations okay
um
yeah and i think that's all i'm going to
say that we can come back to discuss a
bit more at the end
okay lane projection i hope everyone
sort of got this on tuesday
but if not the basic idea is you know
we've got uh some latent variables we're
removing the we're going to come up with
another graph it doesn't have latent
variables
but um you know if there was a directed
path from x to y on which everything was
latent then we put in a directed edge
and if there was some
common cause of x and y
and everything from the common cause to
x and from the concourse to y was lame
then we're going to put in a bi-directed
edge okay so that lets us go from a
diagonal lens to an adm g
okay and that
which doesn't have any latent variables
in it
so for example here i could start off
with this graph and then the
projection the latent projection would
look like this
okay and as uh
and the projection preserves that
algebraic causal structure
um
and it captures the d separations but
some information relating to inequality
constraints is lost and sort of robin
evans work on mdags
is is uh so that connects actually to
question yesterday about hyper edges so
there are situations where you want to
distinguish between
you want to know whether the confound
you know whether there's a single
confounder or whether they're just
pairwise compounders but those
those typically arise for inequality
constraints okay
um i have to give you a notion of what
we call conditional this is not the
world's best terminology but essentially
we want to use this to represent what
i'll call a kernel so it's a
distribution over v indexed by values of
the variables and w's okay
so
uh i mean it's often going to have an
interpretation as v given do w's
but i just want to think about it
abstractly it's just it's a graph with
two sets of nodes and this again
if this seems very similar to swig
that's because it is very similar to
switch but essentially we've got some
random nodes and we've got some fixed
nodes
and we can set the fixed nodes to
different values and those index
different distributions
over the random nodes
um
and we have a factorization sort of
obvious factorization that you would
associate
in the case where it's a dag we would
have the obvious
down factorization okay
so we're going to use v for the random
guys and w for the fixed guys
so
the random guys will represent with
circles and the fixed guys will
represent with squares
and another point here is we're going to
have no edges between vertices and w
they'll the only
edges that there are that involve
w the fixed guys will be edges that go
out of w into
random guys
okay we have the notes of ancestral
descendants
hopefully you remember those from um
from
tuesday the only additional thing here
is i'm going to include each variable as
its own ancestor and its own descendant
okay so here in this graph the ancestors
of y
are
a1 l1 and a0 not l0
okay there's another definition i need
which we'll call district this is also
called a c component by jan
um districts are
in an admg or an adm or cadng if it has
fixed those will be maximal sets
connected by bi-directed edges and they
will always be
among random variables
okay so here these are the
these are the uh
districts
okay um so you might say well why is
that of interest it arises very very
naturally
um and
it arises because
supposing that i had a dag that latents
that gave rise to this adg
then
um you could imagine kind of that you
want to separate out the thumbs over the
okay so i've got
i've got the margin over these variables
i want to sum out u and sum out v
so i can sort of push in the scope of
the sum over u and the scope of the sum
over v if i do that
um i i end up with the
terms that involve the variables that
are in the
district okay so here
i've got one term one district involving
one and two
then i've got another one involving
three and four
but sort of conditioned on one and twos
so you can see
uh and then an uh another term for five
given three so i could write this
i could write this as three kernels
right so i've got this is defining a
distribution over one and two in this
case it's just the marginal over one and
two
i've then got a distribution over
uh three and four conditioned on one and
two
or sort of indexed by 1 and 2. it won't
always just be the ordinary conditional
distribution in what we're doing
and then another one for 5 given 3.
so in general we're going to be able to
write
we'll be able to write any joint
distribution
arising from a diagram latents we can
write it as a product of kernels
for each district conditioned on the
parents of that district that are not in
the district
and these these as i said these are
called c components by tien
okay there's a quick quick comment here
that uh it's important to realize that
uh
you know there was a lot of literature
in statistics where people develop
things called chain graphs and
other related graphs where they put
block orderings on
on sort of things that they were on an
equal footing and then put a dag
structure amongst those sort of block
variables but in general we're not going
to be able to do that so here you know
this is a this could easily arise from a
dagger latency so you can see here that
you know
one has a
one is a parent of three
and um
four is a parent of two so so there
won't in general be a total ordering
that we can put on these districts
or dag ordering that we can put on the
districts
okay uh
so
um in a c a dng so now we've got fixed
and random nodes the district of v
is just the set of things that are in
the district that contains v
okay and a key point here is only
variables in v only random variables are
in districts
okay so in the example here the district
of y
is going to contain y l zero l one the
district of a one is just a one
and we're going to use
d of g to denote the set of districts in
g so in this particular case that and
that will partition the set of random
variables in the in the graph so in this
case
it will be these
uh that the districts are there are two
districts l one l zero y and a one
okay so now to tian's id algorithm this
is the algorithm that was uh referred to
as the schmitzer pearl algorithm
um
on on
on tuesday
um
i'm calling this because i learned about
it in tian's paper
um
so the idea is to re-express the query
we're going to describe in two steps
the first step will be to re-express the
query
as a sum over a product of intervention
distributions on districts
okay
so we're going to take at a high level
we're going to think of we're going to
re-express y given do x
as a sum over a product
of intervention distributions so where
each term is a distribution over a
district d i
given that we intervene
on
the
parents of the district that are not in
the district
okay
that's the first step
and then the second step will be we will
check whether each one of these terms is
identified
okay
obviously if each if i can show you each
one of these terms is identified then
that shows that the original query is
identified so it's sufficient for
identifiability
but uh
ilia
schweitzer showed that in fact this was
also necessary so essentially
um uh if any term here is not identified
then the original query is not
identified and huang and val taught her
an independent proof of this okay so
there are everyone clear there are two
steps we're going to do first step
is to decompose our intervention query
into these pieces
the second step will be checking whether
each one of these terms is identified
okay
okay
um and then yeah basically once we've
done that these two steps that will be
the whole
you know that will give you a a
complete algorithm
sound and complete algorithm for
identification
um
okay so how are we going to decompose
the query so just keep in mind what the
query is i've got y given do x and some
graph g
where there's a set of observed
variables instead of hidden variables
but but y and x are always observed
so what we do is we remove the edges
into x in the graph this is just
notation to say take the graph g where i
cut the edges into x
um
and
then
we're going to restrict the variables
that are still ancestors of y so why is
this the set that we want the
intervention distribution on so i'm
going to let t be the ancestors of y
in the graph where i've cut the edges
into x
so these are vertices that lie on
directed paths between x and y
after cutting edges into x so
equivalently t are variables on proper
causal paths from x to y
okay and then
i'm going to let g star
be the graph formed from this by just
getting rid of everything it's not in t
then i'm going to find the districts in
this graph g star
and then i'm that's the end of the first
step so i will then
express by query in terms of uh the
product over all of these districts in
g-star
the district given that i intervene on
the parents of the district of the north
in the district
take the product of those and then i sum
out anything
that i um anything that uh that i don't
uh
that i don't want so anything basically
is um
random so it's not in x
and it's not in y
so t in general is also going to involve
vertices in x
so let's look at some examples of this
first step
so here's our friendly front door graph
now i've looked at the latent projection
i've got rid of the hidden variable
between x and y
and now um so now the first step of the
crew so i want to get the effect of x
and y here
so here's the graph where i cut the
edges into x
okay and now i take the ancestors of y
which in this case is everything
so g star just is this graph
and now i look at the districts to the
left and its graphs here the districts
are y and m
and so then the distribution of y given
that i intervene
uh on x is just the sum over m
the product of the distribution of y
given dou x and y given do n
which is the this is the expression that
i gave you
you know that i sort of used as my way
of
deriving the identifying formula for the
for the uh
for the front door but here it's
dropping out of the
first step of this algorithm
let's look at this is back to our
sequentially randomized experiment this
is the graph that you saw previously
with abcd
here i've been undoing the the sort of
jamie robbins uh sequentially randomized
notation where a0 and a1 are treatments
l1 is a
an initial response and then y is the
final outcome and here you know it's the
same query as before except instead of
it being uh d of
a c it's now y given do a0 a1
so let's look at this
we're now going to intervene on a0 and
a1
we're going to look at
the ancestors of y so the ancestors of y
now in this graph
are going to be a1 and a0 that's because
i have no directed edge from l1 to y
and
i'm now going to
form
a form g star where i get rid of the
things that are not in t so l1 is not in
t so this is g star
and then i can see
that there's only what the decomposition
is sort of trivial because i've only got
one district here which is y
okay so that's the end of part a
so now we're on to the second part which
is so i've now i have to work out
whether each of these
terms is identified so you're going to
come up to me with some district in our
target
graph
and we have to find out is it possible
to identify
the distribution on d when i intervene
on the parents of the district they're
not in the district okay
so what am i going to do i'm going to
find an ordering
of everything else that is not in the
district
what i would like to do is say suppose i
could find an ordering
of everything that is
observed but not in the district
such that
um if the distribution over
such that if the distribution when i
intervene on r1 up to r t minus one
the distress of uh when i intervene on
those things on
everything remaining in o
is identified
then
the distribution when i intervene on r1
up to rt minus 1 and rt
is also identified okay so what i'm
saying is
can i come up with a can i come up with
an ordering of everything that's
observed that is not in d
such that
uh that that um
i can sort of incrementally intervene on
each one of those things that is not in
d
and these will all be identified okay so
this is sufficient for identifiability
because obviously when i start off the
base case is trivial i don't intervene
on everything obviously p of o is
identified because i'm giving you the
distribution of the observed variables
and then you know i would then get that
i could get uh the distribution over
um
over d when i intervene on everything
else
and then it then follows uh you know
that
if i intervene on everything else then
everything except the parents of d that
are not in d will be causally irrelevant
so this so this guy
so this is the distribution over d this
guy is d because i've removed everything
that was in
o but not in
d and here i'm interviewing on
everything else
but if i interview on everything else
then
causely the only things that matter are
the variables that are parents of d but
not indeed
okay so now a bit of terminology i'm
going to say that the vertex rt will be
fixable given that we've already fixed
r1 up to rt minus one okay and you might
be saying fixable is this just is this
just yet another synonym
for
for intervening and the answer is no
because fixing is so it's it differs
from do or cutting edges because
if a variable is fixable it means that
the the um
that
we can identify the effect of
intervening on that uh variable given
that we've intervened on all of these uh
previous variables
so i'll make that clear in a moment an
example
so what do i need to do so i've given
you this overview of how we're going to
go about checking this how we're going
to come up with the criterion for
checking whether or not this is uh
identified so we need to do two things
we need to give a graphical
characterization of what fixability is
and then we need to i need to tell you
how we're going to construct the
identifying formula
okay so first the set of fixable
vertices so i'm going to give you a
graph g of v w
w are the guys we've already fixed v via
the guys that are still random
and then we'll say that if
we define the set of fixable vertices
the vertex is fixable
if
there's no other random vertex
that is both in the same district
as v
and the descendant of z
so vertex v and v is fixable in g if
there's no proper descendant of v that
is in the same district as v in g so
maybe if you think graphically it means
v is fixable if there's no other vertex
y
such that both
y is in the same district so connected
to v by a bi-directory path
and y is a descendant of v
okay so the set of fixable vertices is a
subset of v
and it contains at least one vertex from
each district in g you could see that
immediately if you just think about the
district if i give you a district then
you can just think about you know if you
find some guy in the district and he's
not fixable
then that means there's some descendant
of that guy in the same district you
could go to that descendant
is that guy fixable if not you can take
another descendant and finitely
eventually you'll get to some guy that
is in the same district and has no
descendant that guy is fixable
okay so let's do some examples right so
here
i start off with this graph
what are the vertices that are fixed for
m and y are fixable
so
n is fixable because obviously there's
no one else in the same district as m so
it's automatically fixable
y is fixable because although it's in
the same district as x it has no
descendants so y is fixable
x is not fixable because x is in the
same district as y and y is a descendant
of x
what about this graph in this graph this
is the
the graph we saw before
a0 a1 and y are all fixable well y is
fixable because it has no descendants
uh a1
is fixable because it's not in the same
district as anything else a0 is fixable
for the same reason l one is not fixable
because it's in the same districts as y
and and why is its descendant
okay
so
i told you what it is to be fixable
now i have to tell you what the
operation of fixing is that turns a
fixable vertex into a fixed vertex
so given a a c a dng given a graph where
the v guys are still random and the w's
have been fixed and e is the set of
edges
fixing is going to be pretty easy
it's just going to consist of
cutting all the edges into the guy we're
fixing and moving the guy we're fixing
from the set of random guys into the set
of fixed guys okay so basically we form
a new graph from the previous graph by
removing any edge
uh that has an arrow header r the guy
we're fixing
and making moving r from being in v to v
and w
okay so it just
transfers r from v to w and it removes
edges that have an arrowhead
um that are into r
okay let's look at some examples
so here
this is x and y remember we decided m
and y are fixable here
supposing we fix m
then we go to this graph
okay
what did we do we we replaced we cut the
edge
into m we made it square
and now
and so now this is a fixed node
but now notice something interesting has
happened
that whereas in the original graph x is
not fixable x now is fixable after we
fixed n
so
you know uh
um
x was not previously fixable but after
fixing n x becomes fixable
about this example here
we saw that a0 a1 and y were all fixable
l1 was not fixable
but the same story happens here
if we decide to fix a1 so if we fix a1
here
then now
l1 is going to be fixed for after fixing
a1 because
although l1 is still in the same
district as y l1
is no longer an ancestor of y y is no
longer a descendant of
l1 so l1 becomes fixable so l1 was not
fixable prior to fixing a1 that l1 is
fixable in the new graph that we get
after fixing a1
okay so so far it's just been graphed
but i i'm promising an identifying
formula here so we better have some way
to generate an identifying formula and
so that's how this is going to work
so given a distribution given a kernel
over v given w we're going to associate
transformation
corresponding to fixing
and that our transformation is going to
be fairly simple
we're just going to take our existing
distribution and divide by
the density for r the guy we're fixing
conditioned on its markov blanket
where here i'm defining the markov
blanket
so that there are other people that
there are slightly different definitions
of this term but basically here it just
means
those guys that uh that are connected to
by a path
um that uh
has an arrowhead r
and every vertex every non-endpoint
vertex on the path is a collider okay so
it's basically
it's the parents of our
it's everything that's in the same
district as our and it's the parents of
uh things that are in the same district
as ours
so we divide by the conditional
distribution are given the other
vertices in the district containing our
under parents of devices in that
district
okay and it can be shown that if r is
fixable in g
then
um
then
this fixing operation corresponds to
what you would expect given the word
fixing which is it corresponds to taking
as input the distribution over v given
that we intervene on w
and after this operation we end up with
a distribution over v minus r given that
we intervene on w and r
okay
okay so just to sort of aside here this
operation
of fixing
it generalizes my unifies and
generalizes my slicing and conditioning
okay so
in the case where the markov blanket of
r
is everything else except r
then this operation is just maximizing
because basically i'm taking v given w
and i'm dividing by r given everything
else
which means that i just end up with the
minus number v
[Music]
minus r conditional on w
conversely in the case where the markup
blanket of r is all of w does not
include any random vertices
then fixing corresponds to ordinary
conditioning
i'm just doing this
in the general case fixing it will
correspond to re-weighting so in the
general case which isn't between these
two so isn't the case where it's
everything where the markup blank is
everything else or the case where it's
only the fixed verses it will
correspond to a re-weighting operation
so we'll get the new kernel that we get
will will not be either a margin or an
ordinary conditional distribution
okay so a key point here is and this
this is a sort of contribution here that
tian's algorithm the id algorithm and
also i think the first you saw on
tuesday had both a factorization
operation and a
and which was the recursion and also had
a summation operation so here we've
we've collapsed these both into the
single operation the single fixing
operation okay
so this is basically uh uh
in substance this is leading up to what
ilia already alluded to this camera but
i think in the chat on tuesday which is
we're going to have a one-line version
of the id algorithm that's where this is
leading up to one line given some
notation
okay and we're so we're also we're going
to want to fix
a whole sequence of things and so we're
going to want to compose fixing
operations and we'll do that in the
natural way
so if i fix s and then fix r
then that's just going to correspond to
taking the original graph fixing s and
then fixing r in the graph after fixing
s so graphically it's sort of
a no-brainer it's a little bit more
subtle when we do that with
the the kernel so we first
we take the kernel over v given w with
the graph g and we're going to fix s
and then now when we fix r we're going
to take the kernel that we got out of
that operation and then we're going to
you do that with the graph that we would
that we got after fixing this
okay so
that's that's basically uh
that's basically it
so our goal remember step b of
identification was we wanted to identify
the district given that we intervene on
it
on
on the
parents of the the district that are not
in the district for all the districts in
our graph g star
so here let's look at the front door
graph
right remember
this was our target g star
there are two districts here m and y
right remember the reason we're
interested in those is because we've
decomposed our query into this sum over
m product of these two intervention
distributions
so now we've got to check is this term
identified and is this term identified
so that's what we're going to do
via fixing
so
the first one we're going to look at m
is this
is the distressed over m when we
intervene on the parents of m which is x
here is that going to be
is that identified so we're going to use
fixing to check that well i start off
with this graph y is fixable here
so we fix y
that takes us to this graph
now in this graph
x is fixable
right x wasn't fixable up here
but it is fixable after fixing y
because now
x has no descendant in the same district
as as itself so now we can fix x
so this proves that m given dx is
identified and in this particular case
here so this this step is just
corresponding to maximization and this
step just corresponded to conditioning
so you know as we would expect and given
do x here is just a distribution of n
conditioned on x
okay that so we've done one of our
districts now we've got to do the second
district y
so can we uh fix everything that's
outside this district
okay so
we obviously fixing y is not going to
work we have to fix everything outside
the district so we're going to have to
fix m
fortunately for us we can fix m here
because n was fixable
because although it has a descendant y
it's not in the same district as y we
fix m
and now having fixed m we can fix x
because x is no longer an ancestral y so
we can fix both of those
and that proves that y
given uh do n is identified and if if
you if we went through and checked this
we would
see that the identifying formula
uh
corresponds to
the backdoor form a little bit of
algebra required to do that but that's
what we would get
the backdoor formula for the effect of m
on y
controlling for x
okay let's go back to the this example
okay so here remember we just had a
single district that was good
right our target graph
the target graph we're looking for is
this one down
we're looking for a target graph
target graph that we're looking for is
this is our target graph it only has y y
is the only
district in our target graph when we
intervene on a0 and a1 and take the
ancestors of y
so back to this
okay so here
um
you know well what can i fix i could fix
a0 or a1 supposing i fix a1 i get for
this graph
having fixed a1 i can now fix l1
having fixed and that now i can also fix
a0
so that's then established that y given
that at
i of intervening on a0 and a1 is
identified
so review
tan's algorithm via fixing
we re-express the query as a sum over
product of intervention distributions on
districts
uh
and that we do that by cutting edges
into x restricting diversities that are
still ancestors of y and finding the
districts that regarding our target
graph
step b is then checking that each one of
these intervention distributions are
identified and we do that by iteratively
finding a vertex that's fixable
after we fix the the previous ones
and if no such vertex exists then this
piece is not identified
and the result of ilius then
establishes that in in that case this um
this
query is not identified
so here's a not identified example
right so if i had this looks like the
front door graph but now we've got a
pesky bi-directed edge here
so uh if you know if i wanted to find
out could i get
the effect of x on y
there's one district y here
but now um
the only fixable vertex in the original
graph is y
i can't fix x because it's in the same
district as y and it's an ancestor of y
i can't fix l
because it's in the same district as y
and it's an ancestor of y so i can't fix
either of these so we see that this is
not identified
okay um
okay and so
um
so we will also say
that um
so one other notion we've got here is
we'll say that a
conditional graph is reachable
from the original a d and g if there's
an ordering of the vertices
um there's an ordering of the vertices
in w
such that we can go from
such that by a sequence of fixings we
can go from the
original graph to this this guy
okay um
so something you might be wondering
about here is
well you might be thinking could there
could there could be multiple sequences
that fix the set w
however under the model
they will all result in the same graph
and distribution so
so basically
that's because um if two vertices are
both fixable at the same time
um
then
then under the model that we're
considering
you can fix them in either order and it
won't change the kernel that results and
it won't change the graph the
results and so that that's that that's
good because it means that we can
greedily fix vertices without worrying
that someone else can fix the wrong
vertex we're going to cut off our chance
to get identification
um
and that also means that if if this guy
is reachable from here then the
corresponding kernel is uniquely defined
okay
so
so the last thing here this is the one
line this is pretty much the second last
slide here this is the one line id
algorithm that uh ilio mentioned
previously
so
we've been talking about step b
but remember what we did in the
algorithms
we did
we we re-expressed our query in terms of
these districts in our target graph and
then we checked whether each one of
these was identified
we can talk about abstractly we can
think about the set of all districts the
set of all sets that arise that are
bi-directed connected that arise that
can be reached by fixing
okay um
and we call those
uh we call those intrinsic sets
so
so we'll say a set d is intrinsic if it
forms a district in a reachable subgraph
okay so if d is intrinsic in g then from
what we've shown
that this reached over d when we
intervene on everything
that is a parent of d but not in d is
identified and we'll let i of g denote
the set of intrinsic sets in g
so here we are here's the one line id
algorithm
if you give me a graph with hidden
variables and observed variables v
apologies for switching notation
and then with a latent projection g of e
and then you come to me with an a and a
y
is what we're intervening on y is the
response
these are subsets of the observed
variables
and we'll let y star that's the that's
just the
the set
that uh that's the ancestors of y
in the graph where we uh
cut all the edges into things in a
then if it's the case that the districts
in that uh that graph that we form this
is our target graph if that set of
districts if all of them are intrinsic
then we have identification and the
identification
you know at a high level i want you to
understand it's just a sum over products
of these
these uh uh kernels okay the these
pieces that look like this so these
things again
play this role
they play the same role that we saw that
v given parents of v played in the
simple fully observed case
and correspondingly if there's some
district that is not intrinsic
then um then this guy is not
identifiable
um
yeah and and the question that arose
the camera on tuesday was about
efficiency of computing this
um
so sort of once you've got this
identifying expression how quickly can
you compute this this it could be a big
sum
so we do give an efficient algorithm for
computing this using the factorization
um
and just to connect it to terminology it
was also used on on
on tuesday um so earlier
uh characterized sort of yin and yang
aspect here earlier characterized
structures called hedges that are those
interventional distributions so they're
not identified so sort of hedges and
intrinsic sets are sort of
uh yin and yang okay so if you give me a
bi-directed connected set and it's not
intrinsic then there exists a hedge
so
um
yeah so
the hedges are the
the sort of the uh
the
unidentified bi-directed
or
intrinsic sets of them uh sorry
bi-directed connected sets that are not
intrinsic
will give rise to hedges
so if if that is intrinsic that proves
the non-existence of a hedge for that
set
okay
so now
this is the sort of
trailer to say
so i've shown you the id algorithm and
whilst going through the idea and we
cast it in this way we developed some
sort of graphical notions
and then these notions can then be used
to construct a class of graphical models
that encode these constraints that
generalize development constraint
generalize
ordinary conditional independence
constraints and that describes a model
called the nested markov model we get
finer factorizations
we have parameterizations we can test
and fit these models we do not yet have
equivalence theory or search
and
that's it here are references on
identification of nested markov models
and here are uh
papers on parametrization and
completeness
and then
this is like the
this is like the post-credit
uh
sequence this is to show you i i guess i
don't need to do this because i in
certain sense
the quest that was asked earlier about
what were causally intellectual
functionals in some sense answered this
question
um which was you know
um
yeah
why do we want to come up with a model
that's defined that's characterized by
these constraints but i will stop there
thank you very much
uh i have a question about the earlier
materials about swig so i just wanted to
ask what is a different interpretation
of a different labeling of the of the
swings
yeah okay let me go back to that um
okay
so
um
so okay so
in a certain sense that so we can make
this precise at this point but
essentially the idea is
okay
in the potential outcome framework
so if we think about factorization
modularity those those equations between
distributions in fact right you know um
modularity is an equation between a a
conditional distress in the observed
distribution and a conditional
distribution or a part of a distribution
in our counterfactual distribution
that that sort of seems unnatural to
someone that's you that's that's used to
thinking as a potent in terms of
potential outcomes right so in fact this
came up when i was presenting the online
course infrastructure
people said wait a second you know what
what's this you're talking about in fact
i think one of my courses said
uh what is this you're talking about um
surely it makes much more sense to think
about this
you know what what is this thing it's
sort of abstract uh nonsense to think
about this uh it's much simpler to think
about
you know well i start off with this and
then i then have independence which gets
me to this and then i then get you know
i then
uh that i can then use the fact
that um
that conditional on x equals zero
under
consistency
this random variable is equal to this
random variable
right that's how consistency works
consistency says
you know that i think about among people
who for whom x actually is zero
the actual y value is equal to the value
of y that it would have been had x been
equal to zero
but
there are people
i guess phil david and sort of other
people thinking that way
who have said they don't really want to
think about equalities or like um
between
random variables in in passively
observed distributions and in
interventional distributions
okay
and so
so essentially they want to have
they want to think about consistency
they don't want to have equalities
between between random variables and
that partly mo that's one motivation for
for uh d for having this labeling um in
the sense that
may not seem like a very strong
motivation but that's one motivation for
doing this because
essentially you know we can then
have completely different
random variables in each swing
each swig where we intervene on
different sets of things has completely
different random variables in it so
that's one motivation for this uniformly
it might seem like probably seems like a
really weird motivation to people that
think in terms of potential outcomes
but
uh in terms of the
that's that's one way of thinking about
it but i in the same sense this example
i think
the temporal one perhaps is more
i think yeah so maybe i can um
so so suppose for example that
um you want to put down a model where
you say that
a that you you allow for the possibility
that a has an effect on c
at the individual level but you want to
have the
average control direct effect of a on c
when i intervene on b b zero so i want
the average control direct effect to be
zero but you don't want to be committed
to assuming that the individual control
direct effect is zero
right then in that case this is a
natural representation for what's going
on right it's saying that
um that you know
um
cfab
uh will be um
uh you know will be independent
of uh
um what will be um
essentially that we're allowing for the
fact that c of a b could still depend on
a
um
but
we are
um
at the individual level but we're not
requiring it won't won't depend on it at
the um
at the
distribution level
so yeah so so the short answer here is
the uniform one i think is just useful
because there are times where it's
useful to be able to
to uh to talk about the variable and it
be immediately evident which graph
that variable is in and then the
temporal one it makes sense if you're
trying to do what we call population
swing so swigs where the absence of a
directed edge corresponds to
a stochastic exclusion so that
an
average control direct effect being
absent not necessarily assuming as you
would in a non-parametric structural
equation model that the individual
causal effect is zero
i don't know but that was yeah thanks
just to be clear the temper one means uh
everything by topological ordering of
the bag would be right
yes but yeah it could be but i mean it
could also be in general you could have
you know your dog might not fix the
topological ordering of everything
so so in particular you know i mean
supposing my dad the dad could be
compatible with more than one
topological ordering
right but the temporal means all the
descendants
so temporal i mean temporal here means
that i fix the topological ordering and
i order i label everything that is later
in the topological ordering which i'm
thinking of as time
with the with the later interventions
yes
thanks
i don't see any other questions in the
room uh
i
think
the questions of luke are answered
directly
so
thank you again
thank you very much
thank you and thank you for being
willing to put up with this weird format
tomorrow we're back to uh
chandler expires is
for those who are here
if you want to